is it time to quit your job I'm gonna
answer that question in today's episode
of ask Evan so Theresa gots a question
one of our YouTube followers Jenny Marie
love you guys wrote in to say how can I
quit my job to pursue my passions for
the publishing industry I love what I do
I'm even going to attend school for
business so I can learn to manage the
business and publishing I don't want to
waste time stuck in a position I'm not
happy about so there's a fantastic
question that I have three bits of
advice for you
number one is work to learn if you're
gonna have a job
you don't want it being in an industry
that you hate right you don't want to
wake up and go to a job that you hate
every day that is sucking your soul
you're not gonna be a happy person
you're not going to create anything
great doing things that you hate doing
so number one is find a job where you
can learn the main reason to work is to
learn right don't find the company
that's in publishing that you can work
with to get as close to the entrepreneur
founder as possible learn as much as you
can you're getting paid to make mistakes
and learn about the industry take on as
many responsibilities as you can don't
just do what you're hired to do because
remember you're there to get an
education
of the published industry so that when
you start your business you're ready to
go number two is start part-time you
don't want to jump fooling on your
business full-time right away a lot of
munchers make that mistake they go
all-in they have you know three months
worth of savings and when those three
months run out they haven't had their
business take off yet their stock going
back to the job market start part-time
find ways to spend time working at
whatever job where you're learning but
then also putting at least half an hour
every single day into your business to
start getting momentum start taking what
you're learning at your job right we're
working at the job where we're learning
now take that information put it into
your business and start applying it and
building momentum for your company and
number three is quickly you can support
yourself the time to quit your job pull
out and never go back to have another
job again is when you're earning enough
from your business that you can support
yourself you don't have to be making it
rich you don't have to be you know
rolling in the cash you're not living a
life of luxury but you can pay your
bills right you can pay your rent you
can put food on the table you can pay
that electricity bill that's the time
where you can quit and go full-time into
your company so remember work to learn
start part-time and quit when you can
support yourself I'd love to know from
you guys watching if you're in your
business full-time yet or not and if you
are when did you decide to quit your job
what was the moment that you decided I'm
gonna quit my job to focus on this leave
it in the comments below I'd love to
hear from you thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon